>> ♪ ♪
>> WELCOME BACK TO THIS SPECIAL
EDITION OF "HANNITY."
ON THE HEELS THE PEACE DEAL
BEHIND THE UNITED ARAB EMIRATES
AND ISRAEL THE PRESIDENT IS
WORKING OVERTIME.
MIKE POMPEO IS CRACKING DOWN ON
THE COMMUNIST PARTY OF CHINA.
POMPEO’S GOAL IS TO LEVEL THE
PLAYING FIELD AND RESPOND TO THE
RESTRAINTS CHINA ALREADY HAS IN
PLACE ON AMERICA.
THIS COMES AS TENSIONS WITH
CHINA SEEM TO BE REACHING
A FEVER PITCH.
YESTERDAY THE PENTAGON REPORTED
CHINA’S PLANS TO DOUBLE THEIR
NUCLEAR STOCKPILE IN THE NEXT 10
YEARS.
AND TODAY DURING AN INTERVIEW
ATTORNEY GENERAL BILL BARR
ISSUED THIS WARNING.
LISTEN.
>> THOSE THREE COUNTRIES,
RUSSIA, CHINA AND IRAN, WHICH IS
THE MOST AGGRESSIVE IN THIS
AREA?
>> I BELIEVE IT’S CHINA.
>> WHICH ONE?
>> CHINA.
>> MORE THAN RUSSIA?
>> YES.
>> WHY?
>> BECAUSE I HAVE SEEN THE
INTELLIGENCE.
THAT’S WHAT I HAVE CONCLUDED.
>> JOINING US NOW WITH MORE IS
UNITED STATES SECRETARY OF STATE
MIKE POMPEO.
THANKS FOR JOINING US.
>> GREAT TO BE WITH YOU.
>> LIKE WISE.
TELL US ABOUT THE ACTIONS YOU
HAVE TAKEN AGAINST CHINA WITH
RESPECT TO THE DIPLOMATS AND WHY
YOU TOOK IT?
>> WE TOOK THE SIMPLE ACTION OF
TELLING CHINESE DIPLOMATS
WORKING HERE IN THE UNITED
STATES THAT THE FREE RIDE IS
OVER.
THEIR ABILITY TO CONDUCT
ESPIONAGE IN THE UNITED STATES
THE TIME HAS PASSED.
THEY NEED PERMISSION TO GATHER
NOW.
THE KIND OF RESTRICTIONS WE HAD
ON OUR DIPLOMATS IN CHINA.
NOW WE HAVE A RECRIPROCAL
ARRANGEMENT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID ENOUGH
WHETHER IT’S ON TRADE OR
STEALING INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY
AND DESTROYING JOBS IN THE
UNITED STATES.
WE WON’T TAKE IT ANYMORE.
WE DEMAND THAT CHINA NOT TREAT
AMERICA IN THE WAY IT HAS FOR
ALL OF THESE DECADES.
>> MR. SECRETARY, BEFORE YOU
WERE THE SECRETARY OF STATE YOU
WERE ON THE HOUSE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE.
DO YOU VIEW CHINA AS OUR
COUNTRY’S GREATEST THREAT, ON
PAR WITH RUSSIA OR AHEAD OF
RUSSIA?
>> THE GREATEST THREAT COMES
FROM THE CHINESE COMMUNITYIST
PARTY.
IT’S NOT A CLOSE CALL.
I ORDER THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
COMMENTS ABOUT THE THREAT
RELATED TO ELECTIONS.
BUT THE CHINESE COMMUNITYIST
PARTY IS BUILDING ITS MILITARY
AND INFILTRATED THE UNITED
STATES IN WAYS RUSSIA HAS NOT
AND IT’S ECONOMIC MIGHT HAS
DESTROYED TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
JOBS IN THE HEARTLAND OF
AMERICA.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WON’T PERMIT
THIS TO CONTINUE.
WE ARE ALL SUFFERING FROM THE
WUHAN VIRUS -- THE CHINESE
COMMUNIST PARTY HAD A CHANCE TO
LET THE WORLD KNOW WHAT WAS
GOING ON.
THEY COVERED UP.
BILLIONS OF LIVES AND WEALTH
DESTROYED AROUND THE WORLD.
THIS IS WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
MAKING SURE THEY CAN NEVER DO
AGAIN TO AMERICA.
>> CHINA AS A MILITARY THREAT.
WHAT ARE THEY DOING TO INCREASE
THEIR MILITARY CAPACITY?
>> THEY INCREASED THEIR DIGITI
SIGNIFICANTLY.
-- BUDGET.
THEY ARE BUILDING UP THEIR NAVY
AND BUILDING UP A CAPACITY NOT
JUST TO BE EFFECTIVE IN THEIR
COASTAL WATERS BUT TO CREATE
POWER THAT CAN REACH ACROSS THE
GLOBE.
THEN THEY ARE CO-OPTING OTHER
COUNTRY HOUSERIESY  -- COUNTRIES
BUILD BASES AROUND THE WORLD.
THIS IS ABOUT THE CENTRAL IDEAS
OF FREEDOM VERSUS AUTHORITY
AUTHORITYIANISM.
WE HAVE SPENT MORE MONEY ON OUR
MILITARY THAN ANY YEAR IN THE
PREVIOUS DECADES.
YOU AND I SERVED IN CONGRESS
TOGETHER.
WE SAW THE STRUGGLE.
-- PRESIDENT TRUMP WILL TAKE
CARE OF OUR SOLDIERS AND SAILORS
AND MARINES.
WE WILL BE READY
>> YOU TOOK ACTION IN THE
CRIMINAL COURT.
WHY?
>> MOST AMERICANS ARE NOT
FAMILIAR WITH THE INTERNATIONAL
CRIMINAL COURT.
IT’S THREATENING OUR KIDS WHO
SERVED IN AFGHANISTAN.
YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN WHO FOUGHT
THERE.
THIS IS A ROGUE COURT WITH
LAWYERS THAT ARE CORRUPT AND
POLITICAL.
THEY ARE THREATENING TO
PROSECUTE AMERICANS TWO ENGAGE
IN AMERICA’S FIGHT FOR FREEDOM
IN AFGHANISTAN.
WE HAVE PUT PRESSURE ON THE
COURT TO TELL THE COURT THE
UNITED STATES DID NOT
PARTICIPATE IN THE AGREEMENTS
THAT SET UP THIS COURT.
WE WANT NOTHING TO DO WITH AND
YOU ARE DARN SURE NOT GOING TO
PROSECUTE AMERICANS.
WE SANCTIONED PEOPLE AT THE
CENTER OF THE EFFORT TO
PROSECUTE AMERICANS.
WE WON’T REST UNTIL NO MOTHER OR
FATHER HAS TO WORRY ABOUT THEIR
CHILD TRAVELING THERE MIGHT BE
HELD BY THIS COURT.
>> THERE WAS A HISTORIC
AGREEMENT WITHIN THE UAE AND
ISRAEL.
WHAT SHOULD AMERICANS KNOW?
WHAT IRAN BEEN DOING LATELY?
>> IT WAS HISTORIC TO WATCH AND
LINTO THE CONVERSATION BETWEEN
PRIME MINISTER NETANYAHU AND THE
LEADER OF THE UNITED ARAB
EMIRATES AND PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HISTORIC PEACE AGREEMENT.
WE HAD THIS LONG HISTORY OF THE
ARAB STATES NOT RECOGNIZING
ISRAEL AS THE JEWISH HOMELAND AS
IT OUGHT TO BE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S DEAL IS
BECOMING TO COME TO FRUITION.
YOU CAN ALREADY SEE THE BENEFITS
TO THE PEOPLE OF ISRAEL AND TO
THE UNITED ARAB EMIRATES.
THE PRESIDENT RECOGNIZED THAT
THE ISLAMIC REPUBLIC OF IRAN WAS
THE GREATEST THREAT TO STABILITY
IN THE US AND OUR SAFETY IN THE
UNITED STATES.
THE UNITED ARAB EMIRATES
RECOGNIZED IRAN HAS THIS GREAT
THREAT.
THEY BUILT A RELATIONSHIP TO
BUILD A COALITION TO MAKE SURE
THIS THREAT NEVER REACHES
AMERICAN SHORES OR HARMS ANYONE
IN THE MIDDLE EAST.
>> SECRETARY POMPEO, THANKS FOR